عمليات اجلاء الاجانب من السودان
السعوديه اجلت 91 مواطنا وسته وستين شخصا
من دول اخرى الى جده دفعه جديده مرتقبه
وصولها خلال ساعات
بريطانيا استكملت اجلاء موظفيها
الدبلوماسيين وعائلاتهم
المانيا طائره عسكريه هبطت في الخرطوم
لاجلاء رعاياها
فرنسا اجلت مئه شخص من السودان بطائرتين
من مطار قرب الخرطوم على ان يتبعهم مئه
اخرون
الاردن ارسل اربع طائرات الى السودان
لاجلاء رعايه اردنيين وعرب وموظفين في
منظمات اغاثيه
مصر بدات باجلاء عشره الاف مصري عبر عمليه
محكمه وامنه ومنظمه
الولايه المتحده اجلت موظفي سفارتها
وعائلاتهم ودبلوماسيين من دول اخرى
روسيا 140 روسيا من اصل 300 في السودان
يرغبون بالرحيل وهناك خطه لاجلائهم
تعمل كل من كوريا الجنوبيه والسويد
وهولندا وايطاليا لاجلاء مواطنها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات